[Music]
International chess professionals
converge in st. Louis for the 2017
spring chess classics welcome to the
final day wrap-up report in the 2017
spring chess classic all of the games
have ended the tournament hall is
cleared out and we have our three group
champions as with many round-robin
tournament the tournament clinching
final round games weren't necessarily
wins for the victors instead they were
draws all three cases however they were
all hard-fought let's take a look at how
things shaped up in Group A third place
is split between five different
competitors who each have four and a
half points they take home $1,800 each
which is the sum of third place through
seventh place prizes divided by five
second place goes to Grandmaster
Yaroslav Zahra book who ended with an
amazing five and a half points and your
group a champion the top champion of the
2017 spring chess classic is grandmaster
VAR a co bein one of the chess club's
resident grandmasters with six and a
half points before taxes he takes home
six grand
here is the champion of the top group
here at the 2017 spring chess classic
version of Cobian var under normal
circumstances avoiding playoffs and
coming in as the undisputed winner would
find someone quite jubilant down here
but you're a little hesitant just a
second ago you were not too happy with
your game that you just played and tell
us why against Cassatt up yam actually I
just realized that I was winning
basically at the very end and it looked
like I was winning but I just I guess I
should have just made me think a little
bit more and find this nice
idea at the very end maybe I can show
that later on yes
but yeah I think it was job which is
completely winning there with this one
idea so I missed it and then it was a
incredible joy and so with the clean
sacrifice he defended well but yeah I
think I was better than tired game so I
was trying to win now what we knew after
all the other games had finished because
you were the last game in the tournament
hall was that all you needed was a score
but like you said you were winning take
us through the game and show it so yeah
I would say the French and I was sort of
expecting this position and because
quesada always played the classical
defence against the French so 91 and I
had all this in my notes but I didn't
have this cleany to was a different move
than I expected I was expecting the Rue
k1 move here with idea you know maybe g4
and block is okay there so I paid
clinics when I spent some time here
because I realized he's got a lot of
ideas here he wants to go to KD 1 c4 and
initially I didn't want to play at 5
because I think I may be very slightly
worse here after takes Bishop takes rook
81 but at then I realized this is
probably the best I have because quite
solid here and I should be able to hold
this position
so I played at 5 and here I think he
made a mistake here because he should
have taken on pass on here it's very
important so he played the move okay t1
thinking that is noticeable and perhaps
you mrs. Clooney Aten was very strong
move and move the Queen away and now I
have Queen B five ideas when he plays c4
and yeah this Queen e8 was very strong
so now he played here we'll take now he
took back with the night I think that
there might be in accuracy also maybe if
you take with a queen but I already like
my position here I have several ideas
maybe I can start with b5 for example
attack the Queen and then if the Queen
moves back I just put a night only 4th
block is maybe slightly better already
because then I can just just play queen
c6 will create my night is very strong
only for compared to this night only 3
here so he paid night here and
I played Queen B 5 and now he spends on
something like another 25 minutes here
and it got a really long time now 94 is
extremely annoying and to look at the 8
ok see one everything is just very easy
to play for black here so I think I made
the right decision it took Queen check
but now it's some problems here because
the dark squares are weak and this night
doesn't have a good square to go to look
at the 8c3 look before and here again it
was very long time and he came up with
only idea again you know to somehow
challenge for the file look at three
Luke T 3 and I played rook cd1
and Luke d5 I think I think perhaps here
I had an option to just play b5 maybe
this is stronger then he captures
captures 96 he should be six takes Queen
d6 and play a position like this what
I'm just clearly at the pond with good
winning chances here I probably should
have done that thinking h7 now III
thought I always said be fine but now he
played this move a4 and suddenly I no
longer can play d5 and if I try to
prepare a six then he takes takes and he
has queenie tree and the b6 khan is now
weak so that's why I went for dish page
for I'm better here but it's not easy to
break through so I tried to create some
weaknesses Bishop c5 this is so here I
was hoping after if I was very long time
and he has an option to sacrifice the
pawn or makes a play a move like 92 but
if you face 92 I feel like I have this
win here Queen d2 attacking the knight
Knight moves anywhere and a bishop g1
and now threat this Queen to h2 mate so
the only way to stop at this Queen g2
and then I just play Queen d1 now
threatening mate on h5 the pawn is
hanging so I think black is just just
winning here
so he played 96 I captured so this I
think black is very good winning chances
here h5 phone is also a little bit weak
I feel like I could have probably played
this better but Queen d5 before not so
easy to win because with the Queen
there's always a chance there will be a
perpetual or something so Queen d1 check
I went for this I repeat it now Queen is
very active I think it's close to draw
now but the crucial part here is where
my opponent played this Queen d6 move
and which allow this check you
completely miss Queen e1 is it so he
didn't see that Queen goes only one and
protects on before it that is just going
to be a draw already but after this now
I think it's probably close to be
winning here so you played here and
actually play the correct move check
which is winning because if he goes now
back I just take the pawn on b7 and just
up 2 pounds so I'm just winning so it
goes here and here yeah this Queen e2 is
just a double question mark here this is
what I realized I can't take right away
because of the Queen g6 trick and if I
take it to still mate yeah so that what
happened again in the game as well so
but here I completely missed at this I
saw the smoke queen g1 I miss the idea
non-threatening mate so he has to go
here now check I miss the idea that I
just exchanged the Queen's and once the
Queen's that offers just completely
winning it takes it can get 6 and g5
this is the way I couldn't want so yeah
it's unfortunate but you know at least
it in this effect the the final
standings and that's to but yeah would
it be nice to win you know this position
so I played the King g3 i p6 and now I
clear the King issue another incredible
defense because it's very difficult now
I'm trying to you know you sort of
insuk's along here so but you found
another good move here and now check I
didn't see anything better here
take and now if Queen f3 I actually win
because of kinky v but queen f1 is just
a nice way to check if I move takes the
Queen side taken ill mate so yeah looks
like the clear cut was right here where
I had the chance to just just buy clean
g1 it felt like winning you know I just
didn't see that they don't see the
exchange of the Queen's Wow bar it's
still a victory for you in the
tournament overall what's next on your
calendar I'm playing in a World Team
Championship in two weeks in Russia so I
will rest maybe to an athlete section
it's all the rest a little bit and just
try to go there with them you know
hopefully in good shape and to play well
for the US team
all right well as the winner you have
the floor anything you'd like to say and
close it yeah I mean this was a great
tournament and I want to take to the
Chess Club and scholastic Center of
samples for organizing this this is a
good opportunity for the players around
my rating range around 2650 to play and
see if they can improve and maybe you
know become 2700 players so they're not
so many tournaments like this a lot of
elite events nowadays for the very top
players but I think this is the missing
link from the you know and now with the
series of this sort of tournaments I
think there will be some really good
opportunities for the players to play
play around the rating range and if they
can perform well then they can maybe
increase the rating coop for sure
Grandmaster vara Cobian and be champion
of the 2017 spring chess classic now
let's take a look at the other groups
going on at the end of this tournament
this place in Group B goes to
Grandmaster Jamil John a Lima Ronde his
friends call him JJ he has five points
and he walks away with a cool $1,000
third and fourth place is split between
grandmasters Alexander Linderman and
Alexander fear who each earned six
points and take home 1750 dollars each
second place goes to Grandmaster
Christian korilla who could not win his
final game
but he still takes home $2,500 and your
Group B champion is International Master
a wonder liang taking home $4,000 also
notable in this tournament a wonder earn
his second Grand Master normed remember
it takes three norms to earn that title
with a rating minimum so a wonder is
definitely on his way we're here with
the champion of Group B I'm talking
about a wonder liang it seems like only
yesterday i talked to you wonder why
that is
well today you came away with an early
draw and we'll take a look at that in
just a moment but what were your
thoughts coming into the day today what
did you hope to achieve well generally i
mean a win would have been the best i
guess but since i was leavened by half a
point and Trula had kind of a tough
pairing I guess black against Slenderman
so I mean the draw wasn't that bad so I
just wanted to kind of play solid chest
see how it how it would go well and you
got the job done in just over 30 moves
gorilla actually could not he really
really pushed he was going for that
point but he could not come away with
anything as black in that game and so
his game it what's weird about
round-robin tournament is sometimes you
don't know if you're one or if you did
not make the tournament placing after
your game you know it's it's it's then
another game which is what happened in a
few cases here yeah so Carrillo lost and
now you have undisputed first place no
playoff necessary let's take a look at
your last round game for the formality
yeah so it wasn't very exciting I
started out with E for he played a5
which is kind of unexpected but he
repeated his same opening that he played
against Alexander sphere in round in one
of the early rounds I think I can't
recall which round it was so I think
sphere played here
c3 and then castles should be Phi's
something like this kind of aggressive
line instead I played Bishop takes c6
which is also another line I think it's
more salt for like with the structure
so I played Queen e2 Queen e7 and now I
kind of mixed up my lines after Knight
d7 should be three is kind of
interesting
yeah after Queen e7 we should be three
nice beauty to the main line because
after Bishop e3 Bishop takes c3 Queen
takes c3 Queen before check is available
for blackened I don't think that giving
up like two pawns should be worth it for
light so as to take with s pawn with
ready after Queen before check c3 but
Nasir castles I played Knight c3
I think gasoline is available but I
wanted to try and provoke the black
queen side so have to be five castles I
thought I kind of gained a temple of 93
and b5 is kind of weakness but after a 5
it turns out it's not so easy for white
so a force kind of logical before my d
1c v b3 and now i kind of understand
made this move 98 and after night f2
Knight d6 night each one with the idea
of like night g3 is f5 and E for just
pretty nasty for light so instead I
played 92 and 92
that's the Bishop e6 I decided to just
kind of go for a draw because I don't
think I can really press for anything
black probably also can't press right
think like let's say after request to f6
real guests one like rook e8 or
something maybe g6 um White has like a
kind of beautiful looking night on b2
that's not doing anything and well
actually two nights that aren't really
doing anything so with only like three
pieces that attacking it's very
unrealistic that way I can actually do
anything so yeah I decided to trade off
all the pieces also looking at gorillas
game I realized that he was actually
much worse so I thought it was unlikely
he was going to win so after Bishop c4
takes takes there's a possibility in
rookie six the idea of like rook g6 and
trying to text and pawns maybe but after
Rick be one Queen h4 the thirtieth Queen
f3 woke up six whiteheads clean f2 which
is kind of nice intake before
we enough Sun wind so very athletic d8
we just chew off all the pieces it's a
pretty trivial job yeah
trivial draw gets the job done yeah it's
not the best headline but it does win
you thousands of dollars so that's
pretty awesome
I wonder what's next for you on the
chess horizon right after Burton I'm
going to play in the Chicago band which
test tomorrow actually yeah so we got
some people from the club they were just
talking about road tripping up there
just earlier today huh yeah their rides
kind of falling apart
so hopefully your situations better well
what else any any victory speech you'd
like to give I'd like to thank the moves
just club for providing this opportunity
I'd also like to thank the producers
especially in fencing for making sure
everything goes smoothly smoothly and
also being able to broadcast to the
viewers each player scoffs during the
round I think that's very important for
the Advancement of chests and I just
like to say that I think this is a very
wonderful tournament I think it was a
great tournament too and I also like to
say that if it's even better because I
won but okay then he's not so mad at
after all well I wonder it's been in so
it's that [ __ ] game
I'm so glad I had a great time too and I
know that I speak for everybody at the
club we love when the players are happy
and that's when the best chess happens
so thank you congratulations again on
group beat and now let's go visit our
friends in Group C let's take a look at
what happened there as we look at the
top half of Group C grandmaster
alexander Simonov came away with 5
points and $2,500 in second place
iliyan is Nick walks away with 3215 and
your Group C champion Grandmaster Sam
seve on with 6 points and $5,000
remember this was the second strongest
group despite being Group C a draw was
all he needed
here he is Grandmaster Sam seve on
walked away against roofing Lee with a
draw now
actually you had clinched it before your
game was over so I was waiting to talk
to you but a draw would have done it in
the in the first place
meeting it could not win his game so
what was your attitude coming into today
what was on your mind well I mean I
decided I'll play my lines and I'll play
for a women you know if I have
withdrawal probably take the draw and
I'll put him and even got a position
with a couple extra pounds but he
defended well and I couldn't find when
they're okay and you're not really sure
if it was winning or not right let's
take a look at the game and played rook
seasick if I take on h6 unfortunately
locate the third rook takes a two and
perpetually I didn't like this I took on
iPod rook c6 daddy ever get Luke c2 but
here and probably here I had to take the
pawn as v g6 King g7 take again black
has passed a spawn I have my deaqon
still unclear I'm not sure of what
winning here enough I played the rubic
you won
oops take - to g6 rook the rook c5 I
thought this was closer to winning and
run but cover I was wrong before looks
for a five would be 14 after I was Kings
coming to e6 and in many lines it
captures the pawn on d6 there's a race
between the a pawn and the F pawn I
could 84-63 he's bringing his regret to
c6 maybe - yeah maybe I shouldn't have
[ __ ] big - a really natural maybe I
should think over could be six or Ruth
p7 and then bring start pushing that one
after this check King lipstick note that
he can't go here because of work h7
winning I pushed the plane he won candy
services this was a good move now when I
push my pawn he's pushing his F pawn and
he's going to put his rook behind the
tone so they push push before I think
this was actually maybe the move that
gave the game away
route before route 57 I'm not sure I'd
be work of six rookie forecheck group
take D 1787 we got four and now before I
Mike ministration put my king on f4
again I'm not sure he plays h5 but the
stroke behind his pawn so it's still
very unclear but at least my king get
shelter here and when you'll see in the
game it doesn't
so I played be 4s 3d files and I think
you found only draw here Ruby g6 this is
probably also natural a6f 213 Queen now
if I play here then I think it just to
draw takes takes takes Bay 7 rook a fate
and I can't take because you take it
back with checks it's unfortunate but if
I calculate it correctly I have a 7
Queen take take rook b8
check check check
forget one berthing okay one rook b8
with gate okay one came here here p6
yeah like witness checks and I'm in time
okay
yeah unfortunately didn't hook up sticks
and found the correct line immediately
rugby six look us one takes take text
here and this is the problem teachers my
rookie that has to go passive to be
three or it would be seven check King c7
and there's an old study with this
position it's a theoretical drop or its
problem is if I push the a pawn I
believe you puzzled
keepers would be Fatiha he plays rugby
five root B seven checking gay
King c3j Ferguson I just don't
disposition to draw public attack with
Ruby d6 or come from behind the table t1
let's take here King Caesar robe do you
want no not look you won here okay five
root k7 check King gleeful yeah and
Roque one individual it can give checks
and I had no shelter and my rock enemies
that's the problem so I put it on the
passive square be three but he defended
perfectly King see something Easter and
Recife this is the only move that drill
it's important that after roots III
check King b7 King before you for
checkbook c4 he has H five but that's
why he will enter G fo b6 and he puts
the king I ate six and get the same
fortress as takeout in the game so I
give check and unfortunately rooks on
beat three fits on before the positions
winning zombie three after King b8 t b7
i play a six check out the point after
King b8 I defend the pawn which is
hanging now he goes to b7 now I can't
play six check because of King takes AC
could be sudden wrote a five check and I
can't go to be too
so I put her before the raccoons now and
there's no fortress Klingon [ __ ] with
an internet fortress even if I put my
rock on c5 there's no protest Freud
let's say I played Brookes t4 Brooks t5
is adjusted to deaf culture so I put
King b3 and Jo and then when is you the
second most prestigious group in this
tournament Sam what's coming up next for
you in the chess world actually to my
I'm going to claim the Chicago open like
there's a theme here yeah it's going to
be a big event that's going to be
awesome so you're no rest for the weary
huh yeah anything you would like to the
floor is yours anything you'd like to
say I'd like to think through measures
for indoor use to this design this is a
will attend descendant happy to be
person and we hope to have you back
again Sam congratulations on group seat
it's been a great one everyone let's
wrap this thing up the 2017 spring chess
classic was really a chance for the
non-elite grandmasters to showcase their
skills and gets better a lot of these
competitors don't get the chance
normally to play at this level and thus
to advance their careers the st. Louis
chess club is committed to filling that
gap and holding these tournaments the
quarterly series one every season it's
quite easy to remember join us for the
summer chess classic later on in a few
months until next time Ben Simon here
for the st. Louis chess club saying so
long from the Show Me State